yes I was I mean just looking over your
history I mean you start with crashing
that was Jack and then it was uncharted
and it seems like it grows from a more
mature Stelling storytelling standpoint
with every game I'm a jack got into some
pretty dark territory and obviously
uncharted she's almost like a movie in
the way it stolen last of us is almost
like the pinnacle of that so far but
there's always been like that sci-fi
fantasy element thrown into all of them
why do you think that you still
introduced that in stories that are
realistic otherwise like The Last of Us
was really grounded aside from the
zombies infected yeah we actually yeah
well I'd say that we tried actually to
create a story in a world without them
but what it brought was a level of
tension that we could all it's a
palpable tension because you've played
through scenarios with the infected and
you know the difficulty that they bring
to your own you know play experience
that now I can project that same tension
onto all of the surviving humans inside
of that world that without that kind of
pressure that external pressure being
applied you can't really understand why
they're making the choices that they're
making to kill one another and you know
take some of these shoes you know and
one for life
one thing we tried early on to do with
the stories say do we need to infected
because you could tell a story about a
plague and it's just about people
getting sick and what we found was that
then it's all exposition like people
talking about a disease but I don't get
to experience it the other day were
making a survival action game so by
adding the infected back in you could
play what it was like to try to survive
this thing which goes back to the whole
like you know the mantra forever is like
show don't tell you know the more I can
play it the more I experience myself the
more I understand it okay so you're kind
of in the position now of people want a
new life Last of Us like that's that's
what happens in this industry when you
make something that people love like do
you ever feel because regardless of what
happened people either be excited or
they'll be disappointed at first if you
know it's a new IP and then excited when
they see what it is but like you ever
feel
way to this expectations of like you
know fans are itching for something else
in this universe or do you just try to
ignore it all and do whatever your heart
wants you to do you try to do whatever I
mean you can't help but be affected by
that or sometimes like you know we came
off of uncharted 2 and you like what are
we doing how the hell do we top that
game and you know and it's just porn we
just said let's not try let's let's just
do this this thing that which we didn't
think would be as successful as
Uncharted when we were working on it and
it's same thing with the DLC when we
started working on Left Behind we you
know we at some point you asked
yourselves like people have certain
expectations of what this game should be
or how intense it should be or who Elly
is and at some point we're like well
this is what we want to do and we really
want to play this we really like it and
I wish I could give myself amnesia and
play this game now I think would be
awesome you know you mean like but again
we see those flaws in those bugs but
yeah but yeah I mean the even right now
with Left Behind about to you know get
in people's hands sure the single-player
campaign we're super proud of that and
you know that's awesome it's it's beyond
our wildest dreams as far as how it's
being received but now there's this
other anxiety which is like we've built
up an expectation with our fans of like
what the last of us is then here comes
this other story you know and we're
again moving past our own comfort zone
we would like to play left behind if we
knew nothing about it we would be
excited about playing left behind like
what yeah we want to surprise players
like oh wait I get to do this in this
kind of horror survival action game like
I but it's awesome like and that's kind
of how we approached it do you think the
time is past for something like jak and
daxter because yeah I mean like I said
like if the story is actually really
interesting in those but it's also an
Thermo anthropomorphic animals that
don't dominate gaming anymore do you
think the time has passed for that kind
of stuff do you think if you're telling
a mature story you have to go the last
look at Pixar you know as far as like if
if they can tell stories with fish that
make you cry yes lately there's no
there's there's no limb
if it's a good story right if you and
the the trick is you have to make a
believable world as long as you stick to
your own constraints and restrictions
that those characters have to obey then
it doesn't matter what the animal
creature anthem perfect you know
tentacle beast is it's like as long as
the cars yeah it can be cars and or
planes exactly it's not not planes won't
work yeah it seems I mean I've never
talked to you guys before it seems like
you have like respect for your
characters like that's almost the way
I'd classify it and I think that that's
when we love them yeah it seems like
that's like might be one of the cuz it's
you know I mean I love Uncharted and I
love Nathan Drake's relationship with
with everybody's in like Co selling
something it just it seems like just
talking to you like that it might it
might just mean that you respect them so
much that you do write them as people
well from a storytelling standpoint you
you approach a scene from every
character that's in the scene is like as
Ellie what do I want here and what's
stopping me and how far I'm willing to
go to get it as Joel what do I want here
as Henry as Sam as Tess as any one of
these characters I have to have real
ones and have to approach the scene and
that's that's how you're right honestly
and then you kind of have to ignore
tropes or anything else and just say am
I being honest to this character
regardless of what anything what else
might think and if the answer is yes and
that's correct for what's happening in
the scene by putting yourself in the
position of actually exploring like the
you know the inward desire of that
character you're actually it's like
compassion it's it's literally like a
Buddhist sort of method of writing of
like you're you're now allowing to
express empathy you understand now what
another human is going through and then
especially in this world you're
exploring so many different dimensions
that it's not just like one note like
kill the bad guy or save the princess or
whatever that thing is but instead it's
like there's complexities to
relationships and there's a there are
dilemmas you know I want to good things
or I want to bad things and that's hard
choices and but by putting myself and
Neil through these experiences like well
what are they after here
you can't help it to love that the
conflict inside of that person so it
they become they become real so while I
was playing The Last of Us like want to
it kind of felt like the movie closed
here to me in a lot of ways I don't I
don't know if you know this movie but
like it had Natalie Portman and Julia
Roberts and Clive Owen but it was a
bunch of people I didn't like and it was
tough to root for anyone I guess and the
last one was similar that aside from le
there was a lot of a lot of people that
I just didn't think we're good people
but I think one of the things that I
really commend the game for is like
David David David's a cannibal like he's
like you can't get worse than that right
as far as people go but he you
understood why he was accountable which
was really weird for me to have that
like empathy for him like how do you how
the heck do you even do that is like he
should have just been like the this
terrible villain but he was he wasn't a
terrible villain he was just like he was
a real person in a terrible situation
well you start by saying okay clearly
he's a leader and people trust him and
he probably made a lot of decisions that
have kept these people alive probably
really hard decisions and he probably to
be a leader of a group he has to be
charismatic he has to you know be able
to just inspire them to take these
actions so those are all really positive
qualities a person can have but then you
say like okay well he's got some
negative qualities and that's what gives
them kind of an interesting
dimensionality and that's how we what we
try to talk with the Last of Us
specifically is to say this world is so
harsh to survive in it to become an
adult in it you probably had to make a
horrible decision someplace in your life
for I could see how you if you judge
them on that level you might not like
them but for me it's a it's a place of
respect where yeah like you had to make
some horrible like I don't envy this
life and yet people still try to find
their humanity within it it feels like a
lot of what makes a character is not in
the cutscene it's how you act and how
you interpret those actions and the Last
of Us is really great in that regard
because like I felt with
bad killing but I kind of did it anyway
and it kind of made Joel a character I
didn't like his I didn't like myself in
that game so I just I don't know if I'm
like I don't know how other people
approach games like this but you say you
didn't like him like did you still enjoy
him like as far as you could understand
them or he just like I want to have
nothing to do with this guy it was it
was the latter one and I understood him
but it was also just like I really
didn't like him and I felt like every
choice was just like a choice I didn't
and then maybe it is just because it's a
mirror because looking back is I would
have made some other choices but I
didn't like those choices I guess and
that's why it was so uncomfortable and
it was an uncomfortable game to play at
times just because there was so many of
these characters so I didn't agree with
their choices except for Ellie who was
like to you this almost I don't know
just this weird pure beacon of hope in
an otherwise drab world so I don't know
I don't know I don't know what it's like
to create a game like that or if this is
your intention I guess yeah I mean and
again we look at stories that we were
inspired by like Unforgiven with Clint
Eastwood where you have you know a
murderer but it's a murderer with kids
and you're you end up rooting for him by
the end but if you think about it he's
taking a job where he's gonna like take
money to go kill these guys that have
really kind of paid for their crime
already and and he ends up like killing
a whole bunch of lawmen in a saloon at
the end but to me it's he's such an
interesting character to see how he
ticks how like what makes a person like
that tick so do you games games aren't
ambiguous like it's almost always like
I'm clearly the good guy and you're
clearly the bad guy like in this and
last time this is really ambiguous like
is that something that you thought about
in development that you wanted this
ambiguity so so people like me can put
like oh joel is a bad father just
because of my life experience like is
that something you really actively
wanted and took shy away cuz I'm Charlie
was the exact opposite of that yes and
that we wanted to kind of like look we
were like big fans of you know we just
talked about Unforgiven yeah like Coen
Brothers or No Country for Old Men where
all this storytelling is done in such a
subtle way where there's like almost no
music it's so sparse and dialogue
nobody's telling you what to feel or
yank and it's so much of it is what
you're projecting into it that it kind
of makes you a part storyteller in a way
and it and it tells you like if you want
to get something out of this story you
have to be engaged with it you can't
just have it spoon feed you everything
because those are the stories that we
like so like well let's do our best to
create that kind of experience which
means like we're constantly asking
ourselves okay what is this moment
really about what's the least we have to
say or do to kind of convey that and
know more and that's been the challenge
throughout I swear